Europe's economic recovery is entering
its fourth year overall growth is
expected to gradually increase in 2016
and 2017 consumers are fueling that
grave with favorable conditions
encouraging them to spend more public
spending is also picking up in part
linked to refugee inflows adding
temporary impetus to growth investment
has been weak for several years but it's
expected to gradually strengthen given
favorable financing conditions and
growing demand unemployment is still
very high in many member states it
continues to fall though not as fast as
we would like
growth is forecast to rise across member
states although the improvement will be
more marked in some countries than
others
budget deficits and government debt
levels will continue to decrease
overall a number of external factors
continue to act as supportive tailwind
for the European economy monetary and
fiscal policies are also helping at the
same time the European economy is facing
some head winds which are casting clouds
over the horizon
although trade should pick up again as
global economic conditions improve these
clouds could disrupt our exports and
impact confidence the European economy
the recovery continues
you